apples you're on the air hey now i was
looking at ronnie's twitter and besides
for all the titties have you noticed his
love of helicopters on there yeah i mean
ronnie's got a lot of followers i am not
one of them the amount of titty you know
all the graphic kind of ads it's like
looking at porn yeah yeah he probably
knows somebody owns a company and he's
working out some sort of deal it's a
friend of mine's company i know it this
is how ronnie gets friends now
what do you mean he gives him he gives
him uh
hello i was friends with him before
so i i don't know what you're talking
about do you get any rides on these
helicopters
i don't go into helicopters
i love the pictures ron they're ec130
helicopters really
just shut up
i actually heard a sad story about
ronnie
that the furniture was finally delivered
to his new house and it was a lot of it
was busted up what's up with that ron
how the [ __ ] does that happen you don't
know it
and then they delivered it anyway they
didn't tell you anything
no they called us a week ago
and uh told us that there's a
possibility
that you know some of your stuff might
be messed up
but we're not sure was it really bad
like like unusable you should have been
you should have been there when this
when the truck came here
oh
uh i'm sorry you get it i had um
dory covered like last year i wrote
stephanie a poem
yeah because i couldn't really get out
to get a birthday gift for her or
whatever and i put it i had this old
frame i put in a frame i gave it to her
for her birthday so she opened that up
and it was you couldn't even read it
that's how wet it was
now i see the ronnie puppet up on the
screen who's his background is actually
las vegas very inventive guys i lost my
favorite poem
the first stephanie
but i think i can kind of remember some
of it
i'm off to vegas where i'm gonna get
sweaty with cactus and [ __ ] and
temperatures over 101 i'll have time to
reflect time to tinker while i jiggle
stephanie's [ __ ] until she squirts like
a sprinkler
that made me feel better yeah that's
nice let me ask you something
are you upset so much that there won't
be a titty tuesday tomorrow or will it
be titty tuesday oh there'll always be a
titty tuesday and just so you remember
like today is [ __ ] monday
right uh mile high club monday memory
intercourse monday rusty trombone
tuesday uh bagging
uh whip out your wanker wednesday and
who's your daddy wednesday waiting right
thrust thursday though
hey real ronnie will it be a titty
tuesday tomorrow seriously because i
know you're bummed yeah probably okay
good all right then he's not that bad
right
he's got a life goes on howard yeah
exactly yeah hey listen to this robin
there's a guy in the phone claims he
wants to set up a gofundme for ronnie
yes no no no i don't want to oh stop
ronnie doesn't need that
this horrible company did
i'd like to throw in you know 20 100
bucks whatever would help get him
something
go sell a trailer
i probably will
i'm doing good
oh yeah you're doing really wonderful
all right i hope it works out man
all right man all right sorry to hear
that all right all right thanks thank
you
yeah yeah thank you ronnie puppet nice
nice by the way i started a new poem
yeah hey everyone i am mund which rhymes
with fun
which rhymes with [ __ ]
that's all i got so far
that's good keep working on that